we're here creating cultivate you're
delivering a keynote speech what do you
want pitch yeah yeah you're nervous
reach yeah okay okay I didn't know I had
to have a speech ready so yes you've
just made me incredibly nervous what do
you want people to take away from your
messaging like what you're gonna share
out there you know what it's really I'm
really here to just support and offer
any advice possible that can help women
or anybody just trying to start a
company how to thrive within a company
I've been really lucky to have such
amazing partners like my partners in New
York and company and I'm just here to
offer any kind of you know support that
I can I've been in the business now it's
like 20s on the years or something it's
so crazy
and then I've partnered with many many
different companies throughout the years
I've had a lot of businesses that would
be called failed businesses but I don't
know but I don't believe in its what
other people would call it but I don't
believe in failed businesses because
I've learned something from everything
and it's gotten me here so it's yeah
sharing that's important that's the
biggest lesson that you feel like you've
learned find people who really know what
they're doing fine experts in their
fields you know and that's why again
with my collaboration with New York and
company is seven years strong and it's
because they know what they're doing and
I trust them in the retail in the retail
market and they trust me creatively and
together we create and cultivate had to
do it back to seven years ago you first
get into design like what was it about
designing and was that kind of
unexpected for you we're always a
passion it was um
you know I think it was always a passion
but I didn't know it but I always was
like I mean I've I've always linked
memories to how my mother has looked I
can and not in a superficial way I find
clothes to be very emotional so like
special days in my life
like you know now that I'm a mom too
it's like oh I can remember what I was
wearing when we went to our first opera
together or I can remember what my mom
was wearing you know at my graduation
you know obviously I knew what I was
wearing a cap and gown but but you know
what I mean so I really emotionally I
came from an emotional place and then
when you can meet emotion and business
and you know combine that together
that's exciting for me today is all
about celebrating strong women business
women boss ladies what do you hope to
teach other young girls and your girls
about that oh wow there's so much
there's so many um there's so many ways
I can answer that but I guess for me
it's just about taking risks and really
you know asking questions not being
afraid to sound ignorant because at
times were all ignorant ignorant in a
lot of situations well I am to a lot of
different things and I'm the first one
to ask what does that word mean exactly
or how exactly do that or you know you
know you know what's a pension plan
exactly again you know whatever it is
whether it's in the financial world
whatever it may be just ask questions
and take risks and try to take risks
with other people's money if you can and
not with your own that's a good one I do
have to ask you so it's been like five
years since you've done an acting
project but 15 years are you ready for
this
since hitch no girl kidding no it's been
15 years 2005 February I know is it time
for a hitch to like we need the Ewan
Will Smith reunion you know what it's
time for a good show I agree yes you
talk to will about the no well let's do
this
hitch - right you know it'd be fun
because it'd be like now in the world of
like you know all these dating apps
what would hitch do you'd be out of a
job right I could
I don't know anything about that thank
goodness very good it's acting still
even a passion or is it fully designed
right now for you right now it's its
design and I have some other little side
hustles I'm working on I'm to like I get
very superstitious about talking about
things that aren't exactly done but I do
have something I'm really excited about
that's not acting but acting is
something that you know I will always
love it's just like now that I have
children I'm kind of extreme there's
just so many things I won't do like I
won't do most of the movies I've done
and in the past yes you take them into
consideration chorus so a lot of things
are off that list and I don't want to do
anything too violent of course I don't
want to do anything too sexual or sexual
at all or basically like Disney I'm all
yours dizzy that's all that could you do
a Disney movie like I'd like to see you
as a princess Disney Plus I'm a more of
the villain kind of type of girl so yes
I'd like to do I'm more of the Ursula
type you know yeah are you vying for
that role in the Little Mermaid no I
think that's already
I think it's cat really oh well yeah
well I just like I I like the villains
of the Disney movies they're fun I also
have to say you are my favorite person
to follow on Instagram because you
always comment back to people I mean
you're engaging like how do you decide
who to respond to and maybe where to
draw the line and like keep things
personal very good question why okay so
I usually don't respond to guys that's
just out but you never know with
Instagram you never know but I love when
I can feel that it's a woman and that
I'm connecting with her whether it's
feedback on my clothing line or whether
it's just like a beauty tip a mom tip
that I asked them for - you know I love
that connection with women so that makes
me really that's inspiring to me because
posting is kind of stressful and I don't
love it but the comments or what I kind
of like and I'll literally be like you
know with my girls and whatever get a
quick break and I'll be like I answer
ANSWER Answer because I get excited
about that get a little like you know
sparks of energy bike
connecting with other women like I said
I hope there are other women they see
him like their other women yep
were you surprised that you almost broke
the internet with a response about
baking recently yes you had this comment
to someone and you talked about things a
bit an amazing Baker and an amazing chef
I didn't realize that it traveled I was
talking about it come on he's really as
though he's he's um he's amazing in the
kitchen amazing before I let you go
where do you see your empire in the next
five years you know what's interesting
is I don't see an empire for myself
and I think that's more than okay and I
think it's it's something for me it's
just about following what my passion is
at the time and but I don't have this
overall goal of having an empire my
ambition ships from from this to that at
different times and I think part of the
message that I like to get across is
that you don't have to want to have
everything you don't have to want to be
this like supermom super mogul I'm not
and I'm really happy this way but that
doesn't mean that I I'm not I'm super
ambitious and again I love taking risks
I love the business side of everything I
do but I having an empires not the goal
for me
[Music]